some things never change  and i'm holding on tight to you  who are the actors behind the voices for  our favorite characters in frozen two  let's take a look excuse me i climbed  the north mountains  and saved you from my ex-boyfriend so  you know i'm coming  kristoff can i borrow your wagon and  sven anna  i need to ask you a question do you want  to build a snowman  i'm just living the dream anna oh how i  wish this could last forever  tell me you're older and less  all-knowing do you ever worry about the  notion that nothing is permanent  remember our first trip like this when i  said you'd have to be crazy to want to  marry a man you just met  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]